[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
I understand
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
laughs
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
I'd like a water
up
in a whiskey glass
whatever you want John Wayne
[Music]
every time
excuse me
I couldn't help but notice it's a steam
World game you're playing there
well uh I've played all of the
steamworld games
actually helped make them you know
cool yeah thanks yeah it's pretty cool
do you all know a secret about
steamworld something that nobody knows
anything about
sure well there's the story about this
great story Cowboy don't forget your
head
I'll be right back
so as I was saying oh sorry I just
wanted to share the secret about
steamworld
we're actually working on something new
[Music]
thank you
all right folks time to get to work
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
telegraph's special broadcast
you just saw the trailer for our next
steamworld game steamworld build which
is coming to PC and all consoles later
this year
steamworld is Thunder Falls original
series and it was created right here in
Gothenburg
this Swedish city was and still is an
industrial Town traditionally known for
its huge port and also the many
factories that were built here once some
of the British investors came over
during the Industrial Revolution
so I'm here in this beautifully
preserved Relic from that era the
Gothenburg REM fabric textiles Museum
back in the day when this Factory was
fully functional it was steam powered as
were all factories in Gothenburg from
the 18 and 1900s
this huge industrial significance of
Gothenburg in Swedish history was highly
influential when we gave birth to
steamworld as we wanted to create a
series that kept the DNA of the place it
was originally created in
foreign
further into steam will build I wanted
to quickly go over what steamworld is
and share a couple of steam World
related announcements too
steamworld has always been about making
the types of games we at thunderfool
wanted to make with the gameplay that
excites us
and it's an IP that acts as a wrapper
for any genre and allows us to add our
own unique twist to it
steamworld began with steamworld Tower
Defense and then came an action digging
platformer with the first single dig
then we tackled turn-based tactics with
steamworld Heist
Dig Two was our attempt at a full-blown
metroidvania and with steamworld Quest
we gave deck building RPGs a steam world
spin
for every genre we decide to steamify we
always strive to add unique elements and
distill it down to its core Essentials
with extremely tight gameplay and an
accessible design
bringing steamworld back and making it
bigger and better than ever has been
something we've been planning for years
now
I've been working with image and Forum
since the original game steamworld Tower
Defense back in 2010 and steamworld
build is now the sixth Mainline entry in
the steam World Series
as our roster of Studios increases in
size we of course have a lot of people
wanting to bring their own ideas to the
steamworld universe for their next
project
so
as the series expands into new and
exciting directions I will be working
with all of our development Studios to
ensure that the tone the lore and the
gameplay of all our steam World Games
stays true to the series roots of course
build is one of those directions but we
also have more steering wheel games in
development than ever before including
build we're now working on four separate
steering wheel titles back in the day
when we were a small team we had to make
a single game have a break then figure
out what we want to do next and so on
and so on so now as thunderfool we have
multiple Studios and it means we can do
a lot more steamworld things at once I'm
not going to go into details on the
other three titles today but rest
assured we cannot wait to show you more
when the time is rise
for steamworld fans around the world
steamworld Telegraph will be the new
One-Stop shop to get all the latest
information on the series
starting a little later this year we
will be introducing steamworld Telegraph
as a smaller scale Community focused
show which I will host we'll be able to
do deep dives into specific steamworld
news stories or announcements discuss
the lore of our world play past and
present steamworld games and we'll
interview developers and other guests
today's special broadcast has been made
to kick off the return of steamworld
as you look forward to hearing more
about the debut of steamworld telegraph
sign up to the steamworld newsletter and
follow us on social media to be the
first to know
for anyone wanting to catch up on the
steamworld series we have a steamworld
franchise sale available right now on
Steam where you can purchase steamworld
dig steel Heist steam will dig two and
steamroll Quest at insane discounts
which now brings me to steam World build
for anyone hoping to play steamworld
build before release there's a free demo
available today on Steam as part of the
steam base Builder Fest
now let's talk more about steamworld
build and show you the game up and
running so we'll roll the trailer one
more time and then meet you back here
for some gameplay
huh I see it I
chat all right folks time to get to work
[Music]
all right
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
and welcome back I'm now joined by two
of the developers of steamworld builds
who represent our internal Studio the
station which is located in kolsom here
in Sweden and with us we have Sophie
Wickstrom who is the art director he
El and Autumn vasey who is the producer
hi
so guys there's a lot of lore to steam
world that's already established I mean
we have so many games and they follow
like along a timeline if you like this
game leads to this game and you learn
something in this game that tells about
that that appears in in the that game
and so on how does steam will build fit
into the the lore and the timeline yeah
so this is actually a story about a
father and his daughter trying to escape
the dying Earth so in Steam world league
two in the end of the game we see a lot
of rockets departing from the earth when
they when the earth exploding and our
story is one of those Rockets cool so
the steamworld franchise it likes to
take on new genres and mash them up so
that's nothing new so could you tell us
a little bit about how the idea of a
city Builder came about
so actually we always loved as it pillar
games in our studio and we were of
course big fans of the Steel World
Series as well so when we started to to
talk about the collaboration a city
building with with the influences of the
the digging and the mining part of the
Dig games were something that we really
wanted to do could you mention like a
few things that make steamworld builds
like truly unique
yeah so initially we decided that we
wanted to take two established uh game
systems so city building and basically
resource managing and resource Gathering
and create one cohesive experience I
think like um yeah I would say it's like
the Anno series having a baby with
Dungeon Keeper and and we should be in
the right ballpark yeah yeah that's
correct but the challenge of that of
course becomes making a game that is
cohesive and also brings both those
elements into play in one good way yeah
yeah exactly it's always been about the
gameplay right yeah and I mean we don't
mind mashing up genres it's it's fun you
know it's like it's like baking a cake
you take some good stuff and put put it
together and see what you come up with
so that's one thing but another thing is
the accessibility of the games like you
say I mean like you're building a city
but you're also Mining and getting
Gathering these resources and I never
feel that I'm leaving one to go into the
other pretty could you tell me a little
bit about that yeah that must have been
difficult that's what I mean yeah it was
like when we thought about it we knew we
wanted to make a city Builder but going
uh too far away from the original
material in the steamroll games
it just felt wrong yeah you know we
wanted to do the digging and everyone
loved the idea of the old Dungeon Keeper
games so we figured could we combine the
two in a good way but then we had to
figure out how do these two layers
connect how does your actions in the
mind feed into your actions in the city
and vice versa right so we had to keep
this constant flow so that was a big
thing to figure out but of course it's
by unlocking things finding things in
the mine yeah so you know you find I
don't know you find scrap in the tunnels
and you're like oh nice that means you
can create spare parts yeah that means
that you can get engineers and that
means that you can you know go further
in the mine so it all feeds on one
another yeah yeah yeah so so of course
you have to also think about the
optimizing your system like how do I
fulfill my inhabitants and how how do I
make the best of of my city planning to
make it all efficient
steel will build is the first steamworld
game coming out that is in 3D
I mean Sophie like as a as an art
director that that poses a million
questions doesn't it yeah and yeah
because if you do a 2d game it'll always
look the same yeah I mean it's good yeah
we always look exactly like you intended
right there was a lot of challenges with
that first off we wanted to make sure
that we kept true to the original
original material so we looked a lot at
the old games uh and you can see it
reflected in our game like we chose to
keep the blocks in the mind for example
because that's a throwback to your games
it looks good in your game so I change
it but generally for the city we had to
always consider scale of everything
because we zoom out and look at the city
from a far distance a lot so we had to
think of every building a sort of its
own little hero piece as the main
character
meaning that when we designed the
buildings we had to think about
Silhouettes colors shapes and humor
right humor is important so for example
we have a restaurant called Lilly
Goodman which is basically just a giant
cloche that lifts up and down up and
down and it has like some a knife and a
fork that rotates so it's really easy to
see from a distance what it is
it actually took me a while to realize
that wait a minute I can I can actually
zoom in like and look at this and
seamlessly like suddenly I'm looking at
I mean I'm a city planner I'm building
my city and then you go in and you see
the robot sort of walking along the
streets but also like you said like
every building is its own character in
the game and it's just it's magnificent
and also when you're getting close you
hear these things yeah we're gonna you
know pull in references where we can
where it's funny that's that's always
going to happen we have one level that
has a cinema that has a movie playing is
basically just robots looking at each
other like
intensely in the in the game yeah and
then it says uh The Good The Bad and The
Rusty on a sign so you know those sort
of things we also have in one part of
the mind we have a swamp uh there is a
sign have buried in the ground and says
they wear and then there's a robo Shrek
on the image stuff like that you know so
there's one more thing that I feel makes
it unique or hopefully makes it unique
because like when I've played city
builders I've either played on PC
I'm using a keyboard and mouse and it
just is very natural and then I've
played also on my iPad and I think yeah
that that works really well too but
steel will build we're going out boldly
here saying that it's coming to PC and
all consoles yeah so so we decided to
hey we want to make this game accessible
for for everyone on all the platforms so
how do we do that the smoothest way
possible so we decided to hey let's make
sure that we have playable builds every
week and that we decided you in the UI
and the interface so it would work
equally well with a with a mouse and a
keyboard or with a Gamepad and if it did
not then we wouldn't put it in so that
was one big thing because we had this UI
guide tied to tied to the project and so
if he got instructions from Andreas a
game director hey I want to do this and
this and he could basically say no that
won't work on the on the GamePad sorry
and then we just had to rethink it right
so when we did our game test sessions we
had PC players and console players at
the same time time and our developers
got the feedback on how we felt on
console and could you know give good
input like this doesn't work could we
switch this button Etc and I think we
could absolutely guarantee that that all
the players no matter what platform you
are playing on will receive the same
experience as the the PC version so yeah
we're really proud of that well guys
we're going to wrap up here but it's
been yeah such a delight talking to you
guys and I'm so happy for the game and
uh
so 2023 it's it's hitting uh the the
virtual shelves right yeah yeah so
thanks a lot for coming for coming up to
Gothenburg like from Carlson yeah which
so thank you for having us yeah yeah and
I mean to the team who's been working on
this game as well I just want to say
thanks a lot guys because you've I think
you've pulled it off it's really really
nice
thank you guys thank you cheers
okay so to reiterate what we've shown
you today
steam will build is coming to PC and all
consoles later in 2023 we have a free
demo going live today on Steam
all previous steamworld games are
available with huge discounts in the
steamworld franchise sale which is also
live today on Steam
Beyond steam will build we have many
more steamworld games coming so look
forward to hearing about those in the
future
steamworld Telegraph will debut properly
later this year at a smaller scale as
our new community show that focuses on
all things steamworld past present and
future
in the meantime follow us on social
media and sign up to the steamworld
newsletter to be the first to know about
all steamworld news directly from us
and that's our show
thanks for watching and as always we
hope you have a wonderful day and look
forward to checking back in with you
very soon bye for now